[Music]
shanghai is about to enter the fourth
week of lockdown with many residents in
the city of 25 million still being told
that they can't leave their homes to buy
food cindy writes in this week's
magazine that the people in shanghai
have taken to social media to complain
and are using ever more subtle
techniques to bypass beijing's sensors
cindy joins me now
hi cindy thank you for joining us
um you're writing the magazine about
shanghai's lockdown this week can you
tell us a bit about the situation there
for those who haven't been following the
story as closely yeah of course so
shanghai like many other cities around
china has been dealing with an omicron
outbreak the difference with shanghai is
that it's actually one of the leading
cities in china which has been
advocating for living with covid
or as much as possible living with
kovid's strategy so he actually didn't
lock down when it found its first cases
earlier this year which meant that by
the time that it did lock down the
authorities didn't actually know how
many cases there were in the city a lot
of these were asymptomatic anyway so
they spent weeks basically telling
people 25 million residents basically
whenever we're not going to lock down
don't worry
then it did lock down at the end of
march and it split the city into two uh
in order to do kind of one week fire
break uh all the while saying this is
how long it's going to be and then it
extended that indefinitely and it's
currently still an indefinite extension
of lockdown but this whole messy nature
of the lockdown has meant that a lot of
people just weren't prepared for the
siege that then they're living under now
um and
bizarrely you know chinese lockdowns
these days i mean that you can't even
leave your flat in the tightest areas
you can't even leave your flat in order
to get a grocery shopping or anything
like that so it's created this
logistical challenge on top of the
public health challenge because the
government is having to arrange rations
uh online shopping is severely
oversubscribed and then there's just the
sheer number of infections that are
happening in shanghai at the moment and
its peak was about 27 000 in a day meant
that because everyone had to be
centrally quarantined on the chinese
zero cover strategy um that
actually there was you know just not
enough people to transport uh into these
quarantine centers there were not enough
quarantine centers themselves in order
to make this happen so the government is
basically dealing with a lot of
different problems all at once at the
moment
and you mentioned that there's some
quite draconian measures are they having
any impact at all on the virus itself
are numbers reducing is it is it worth
the the sort of the measures
yeah the numbers are reducing so at its
peak uh last week it was about 27 000 a
day but right now it's about it's a bit
under 20 000. so it we do see it coming
down um but you know the government is
trying to get zero covert to happen by
the end of april at the latest and
that's just not looking very good at all
you know it's very ambitious target um
so the numbers are coming down but there
are also questions about how effective
these measures are because under xero
cover policy you're meant to kind of
quarantine anyone who might infect right
but at the moment what we're hearing are
these stories about quarantine centers
potentially having cross infections
where people who are testing negative
are put with people who are testing
positive creating these cross infections
or in these math testings that have
become the norm in china
where people are just kind of scratched
up against each other and there's social
media videos showing this and some
people have started refusing to go
downstairs to do these tests because
they're worried about getting infected
during the testing process um so there
are all these questions where you know
just the sheer scale of infections is
something that china hasn't seen before
and they're struggling under it
and can you tell us a little bit about
these sort of complaints we're seeing on
social media and the kind of things
people are sharing about their
treatments in shanghai yeah so that's
the point i pick out most on my piece
which is just this incredible moment on
social media where so much of this chaos
is playing out online so that people
like me sitting in london chinese people
who are concerned elsewhere can see
everything that's happening and
obviously not every single person in
shanghai will be having a similarly
terrible experience there are those who
are very well resourced well to do who
can get enough food and who can get
enough medicines and who do have the
contacts so i'm not saying that every
single person of those 25 million in
shanghai are struggling but a lot of
people are and they're going to social
media posting phone record phone call
recordings of themselves talking to the
authorities posting videos of
potentially arguments with the police uh
similar things like that a bad treatment
like quarantine centers they're posting
blogs about um people running out of
food people running out of medicine and
all of this is just providing too much
for china's census to
deal with so at the during the time that
we're having these health workers
dealing with the omicron outbreak we're
also having china's infamous sensors
dealing with a social media outbreak and
they're struggling they're really
struggling because the volume of
grievances is just something that um
you know that they can't keep up with
and there was this really intriguing
moment on the april uh on april 13th
between the hours of midnight and 4am
which just seemed like the census kind
of clocked off a bit and people were
complaining about the chinese government
but under the guise of criticizing
america so maybe that's why it didn't
trigger any warnings with the ai that's
used to scour social media um but you
know there was just this hours of just
completely unfiltered deluge of
criticism and um it was a really
heartening moment to see because and i
quote you know this one post in my
article saying this is the real voice of
the people commemorate tonight at least
i know that we are still awake though we
travel in the darkness alone there will
be a day when we have the force of a
prairie fire because people on social
media don't normally see this kind of
negative news but you know it's they're
finding it heartening that the sensors
are struggling to keep up because they
can see that there are other people
struggling
and also a point that i make in my piece
is that the authorities also respond to
social media so if you make a complaint
on social media even if it's deleted
someone somewhere has seen that and we
have seen evidence of the government
basically backtracking or u-turning
because of a social media backlash so
for example one of the early things that
the shanghai authorities did was
splitting parents and children uh when
they were going to quarantine so if the
child was testing positive and the
parent didn't the child would have to go
into quarantine by themselves even if it
was you know a baby or a toddler and
that caused a massive internet backlash
and shanghai authorities have now
backtracked on that so people know the
power of social media it's not just
cathartic it's also effective for
essentially people who don't get to go
to the polling stations um and the
authorities are actually afraid of being
humiliated or causing instability that
start from social media and so they try
to you know placate people and they try
to resolve these issues once they get go
viral
and you get the sense that this is
triggering outrage on a sort of more
national scale outside of shanghai
it's really hard to know but for sure
not every single critic online at the
moment are people in shanghai there will
be people who are you know complaining
about
the inhumanity of the lockdown not
necessarily being locked down skeptic
completely but just the extent and the
inhuman nature that you know some of
these policies for example splitting
parents and children have been carried
out are um but there are also people who
are taking this as a sign of you know
the arbitrary power of the chinese
government and criticizing that and
those are not necessarily people in
shanghai but people who are watching
shanghai and you know i think it's
interesting writing about reporting on
this lockdown throughout the last few
weeks there's a lot of sheldon freud i
think from western uh readers and
observers you know haha china's now
dealing with its own pandemic but
actually for chinese people and you know
for people i'm chinese as well it's
actually very concerning you know it's a
doom-scrolling moment where you can't
tear yourself away from social media
because there's so many concerning
stories it's not funny at all actually
um and so a lot of people in china are
concerned that a this is happening in a
city you know the most economically
developed city in the in the country and
that be it might happen to them later on
as well if something similar uh a
similar outbreak happens so it's it's
really concerning and i think people
some people do draw political
conclusions from that i don't think this
is going to go anywhere though before
you know people wonder if this is going
to be the downfall of xingping or the
chinese communist party i don't think it
will go that far because once they get
this under control chinese people have
do
can tend to have short public memories
and they don't then carry that through
and you mentioned your piece as well
about people trying to get around the
censorship regime can you give tell us a
bit about the sort of the methods
they're using to sort of escape the the
hand of the sensor
yeah absolutely so first of all i mean
just to explain how censorship on
chinese internet works
it's actually the social media companies
themselves who carry out the censorship
they get briefed by the central
government uh probably weekly on what
are the banned topics and keywords then
is the social media platforms themselves
who employ either in-house teams or
external contractors professional
sensors if you will um in order to carry
out um these orders to make actually
implement them on a granular level so
that can be a manual millennials for
example who are apolitical themselves
but actually know far more about the
darkest moments of chinese history than
your average chinese person because they
have to be able to censor that they're
helped also by artificial intelligence
bots essentially who that search for
keywords also scour pictures for
embedded text in case screenshots are a
way to get around that
um and so people get around it by
avoiding keywords instead of
sensitive words like gen full which
means government in china people just
write zf because that's the first letter
of each of those syllables
to refer to the government and that
seems to get around that
people post pictures upside down in
order to get past the ai
analysis of pictures uh and there are
also memes which refer to things uh to
people in the know so for time um a
picture of an empty chair was banned on
chinese social media when the census
caught up because users had started
using an empty chair to signal or to
signify the uh late dissident leo
who received his nobel peace prize in
absentia so the empty chair um and so
all of these ways people have of getting
around things and then also reposting so
you've got this fascinating environment
where the chinese people know that they
are being censored they talk about the
senses openly and they also talk about
the methods of getting around the senses
openly so i read one blog um complaining
about the poster's neighbor who had died
of an asthma attack because he wasn't
seen at hospital fast enough because of
the lockdown and at the end he wrote
something like please if you see this do
not tag the government in it do not tag
any state media in it but copy and paste
repost because they can take one thing
down but they can't take all of us down
so you know it's it's this
dystopian world where people know that
they're being censored and they're
trying to find all of these ways around
it and a lot of the times succeeding so
it's a cat and mouse game basically
and you mentioned about lockdowns
potentially spreading to other cities do
you think the criticism the government
is receiving now is making that less
likely or do you think they're going to
plow on regardless with sort of the zero
coverage strategy if it does spread
elsewhere so i think even zero covert
has degrees um because china has done
zero covered from the beginning from
january 2020 but what is bizarre about
the shanghai lockdown is just how severe
it is because
not only are people locked down and
you know people contact trace and
centrally quarantined something new has
happened in chinese lockdowns which is
that those in the strictest tier in
lockdown in shanghai can't leave their
flats even to buy food and i think that
has caused a lot of the problems for
people locked down because
at the beginning you know you could get
these permits for household you could go
out to do family shopping every other
day
i'm not sure why they have stopped doing
that and the city of xi'an over
christmas when it was locking down
because of omicron was the first to
pioneer this strategy um and that was
the first we saw government rations
being sent out but now shanghai has
copied it but that's not the case for
lockdowns across china so i don't
understand why it is that the shanghai
authorities themselves have gone for
this extreme version and they have been
criticized and compared to other cities
like shenzhen which have had much more
humane lockdowns you know pets have been
able to be quarantined with their owners
children with their parents
it's
confusing it's baffling actually why
shanghai has gone for this um extremism
and uh there's conspiracy theories in
china at the moment that because
shanghai was one of these cities
advocating for living with lockdown and
living with covert from the beginning
that there was this
notion that they need to be made to
suffer because they refuse to lock down
now the people now they need to be shown
that that method was wrong and they need
to be suffering more that is a
conspiracy theory but that is what a lot
of chinese people are wondering well how
did it come to this for you know the
best to see in china um so it is
confusing
and finally before you go cindy um where
do you think shanghai goes from now you
mentioned at the beginning there that
this lockdown was meant to last for a
week do you think we've got me they've
got many more weeks ahead of lockdown or
do you think it's coming to an end so
last week um the city introduced this
tier system where the city was in uh
split into three tiers in the strictest
tier people can't leave their flats even
still for food then there's a middle
tier where you can you know leave your
front door and just walk around in your
residential compound
and then the most relaxed tiers where
you can go to other relaxed tier
neighborhoods um so
that's relative freedom i think for the
shanghainese at the moment but it does
show that the authorities are seeing
that they've gone through the emergency
level of the lockdown now um the
government has given them a target of
actually meeting this week zero covered
and the reason uh they can
kind of come up with a gold like that
even though we've got 20 000 daily
infections is because they actually
count asymptomatic and symptomatic
infections differently so in the
official numbers they only count a
symptomatic infection as the actual
infection of course in western reporting
we add on the asymptomatic infection
because that is you know more reliable
so it could be that by the end of this
week symptomatic infections are have
gone to zero even if asymptomatic ones
are still
around but shanghai is hoping to shake
this off by the end of the month really
um and i just don't know if it will
manage to do that
the government certainly is throwing all
sorts of resources at it um and there
was talk before the shanghai parties
actually getting a promotion before all
of this happened but i just don't think
that's going to happen now
[Music]
so
[Music]
you